Zeman's has been the main topic in
Erlangen for months everyone is
wondering who will keep their job 24,000
people work for Siemens here an entire
region lives off the industrial
conglomerate using their coasts if this
city has the most Siemens employees in
the world if you talk with people here
almost everyone has something to do with
Xion either he works for them himself or
he has a relative or good friend who
works for them flatten fur on da da da
da who does wonder to abide it society
this is an old established company and
people have committed to Siemens and so
I think Siemens also has an obligation
to the people
Givaudan mention for was--before if you
worked for Zeman's your children could
apprentice there and work for the
company too but those days are long gone
now Siemens is restructuring itself to
save a billion dollars Joe Kaiser became
CEO hardly a year ago he wants to make
Siemens leaner and meaner he wants
smaller departments and fewer executives
last month he explained why he is
dismantling the company's structures
educators in beasley condition aim here
is to strengthen and stabilize our
successful areas and to restructure the
areas that need to catch up without a
phone and took by this Vita in fact part
of this is simply a short-term flurry of
blind activity so they can say they're
changing something they're reducing
personnel which pleases the capital
markets so it has a rational side but
unfortunately it also has this
irrational side of short-term margin
expectations which also drive industrial
enterprises Danny my light output
leaving bit personnel reductions are
nothing new at Siemens in the last 10
years their management in Germany has
cut thousands of jobs
this time the brunt of the cuts could
fall on Ellingham this is where Siemens
has managed its energy business but the
company intends to move that management
to the United States and it's not clear
what that means for allegan it's calm
hudson numbers came that mean Elenin
could lose five or six thousand no one
knows the
number of jobs that will be cut here in
Allanon Allanon berkeley campus shift
eagle up cobalt weapons own
restructuring the company is also an
attempt not to abandon the markets to
General Electric without a fight for
years the German companies turnover has
limped behind the u.s. competitors now
GE has won its bid to acquire the French
energy company Alstom in France will
have even greater revenues quit sound
the facility companies try to generate
additional growth by moving in on their
competitors main production in sales
areas this is always accompanied by huge
internal discussions my mission is on
all in town discuss you in fabulous as
the question is whether this is
successful or merely diverts lots of
resources into competing that instead of
putting them where it counts in
developing one's own products rather
than in entangling oneself in
competition in skin feelings in it
because the bidding battle for the
French company Alstom ended in defeat
for Siemens they'll now have to
concentrate on restructuring including
in German production sites Allegan is
just one example among many